this morning on the dish a cookbook
years in the making dedicated to one of
america's most
treasured communities the berkshires in
massachusetts have long been a cultural
and summer vacation destination more
recently a top farm to table dining
destination
but the farmers and cooks who live there
year round haven't always gotten their
due
the berkshires farm table cookbook aims
to change that
one recipe at a time
for a classic slice of americana it is
hard to beat the berkshires
in western massachusetts
from quaint downtowns to breathtaking
vistas
and seemingly limitless outdoor
activities there's a potential postcard
around every corner
but the tourist draws aren't the whole
story woven roots farm is here to
nurture the soil that nourishes the
community two decades ago
jen selenetti and her husband made a
choice
they wanted to build a farm in their own
uncompromising way
the traditional ancestral ways of
farming
are what we are being called back to
and i have an opportunity to offer that
information
and that knowledge keeping to the
greater community
you're sort of moving forward by by
looking back
absolutely today woven roots is a small
but thriving
no-till farm no tilling means less
erosion
and less carbon release but often far
more flavor
for example the first carrots of the
season before you harvest
we always take a moment to just to give
thanks
and so i would encourage you to do that
and it might just taste a little bit
sweeter
there it is here's the first one
soil now sweet
delicious amazing i'm getting more
natural than that
salan eddie story is one of 42 farmers
and chefs told in robert bildner
an elisa spungan builder's tribute to
homegrown harvest in new england
each chapter of the berkshires farm
table cookbook features recipes unique
to a particular place people who go to
farmer's markets need to know this that
this is what went into
the tomato that they're about to pick up
and it's an extraordinary amount of work
extraordinary amount of love there's a
great variety we have meat farmers we
have cheese makers we've got
amazing vegetable growers the builder
family has been in the food business for
three generations
robert and elisa once owned a food
processing company
but putting together this book was an
awakening for them
over seven years we've traced down dirt
roads we didn't know
existed it really takes a lot of
persistence to do this
i mean we've literally been out in the
fields
with our recorders and it's taken years
to get
people to call us back and back and
forth and
and i did the photography of the book as
well um
you've been on the ground and and in the
ground on the ground in the ground
jeff it's been a labor love for us i
remember taking notes
in a field of watercress um and i didn't
think my computer was going to survive
because literally it's in mud
when i was you know was taking notes um
that's the way to do it
of course of course i wish i had your
sound crew too
my mic wasn't so great
to compile the cookbook husband and wife
worked with chef brian elberg
who grew up here then was trained with
the world's best
what does farm to table mean for you to
me it just means what i've always done
he's now the executive chef for over
half a dozen of the region's top
restaurants
with your training you could have done
new york city paris
whatever else you chose the berkshires
why yeah
it's it's unpretentious it's communal
it's just a you know this this business
is so stressful
that it's it's really comforting to be
in the business with other like-minded
people that really
want to cultivate the agricultural
aspect of it and respect the arts
um and and our craft so it's nice to be
in that environment
for us elberg prepared a berkshires
feast
all recipes found in the book harissa
grilled cauliflower with sweet corn and
avocado relish
salad with kale egg rice wine vinegar
and smoked almonds
grilled carrot bread with cranberries
and garlic scape butter
grass-fed beef top round slowly cooked
and white bean soup with sausage and
kale all of the ingredients came from
within 50 miles
most within walking distance albert
topped it off
with a brand new creation okay the
cocktail so this is called the bartlett
okay and it's named because one of my
employees
brought in raspberries from bartlett's
orchards today so we made up a cocktail
with it so it's
bartlett's raspberries mint lime
and berkshire mountain distillers vodka
cheers cheers
you made up a cocktail today this
morning based on the ingredients that
were available because they asked me to
make a cocktail
that's how we roll that's what we do
i'll roll like that i will make a
bartlett for you this weekend
i love it yes what a great moment to see
all of that you can
almost take it in without even being
there it's just wonderful to
pay attention and to see some parts of
the berkshires that don't always get
that
attention it's really cool